who was one of the worst first-person
shooter characters up until recently
when he was fixed by ubisoft
no surprise it's tachanka and it's
because he carries a light machine gun
but for this piece we'll shorten and
just say lmg
lmgs and multiplayer shooters have a
long history of identity crisis from
battlefield to call of duty to apex
legends so let's look at why light
machine guns are so hard to get right in
shooters if you're someone who uses lmgs
despite their flaws make sure to hit
that like button and consider
subscribing to the channel
if you're not well let's dig into that
now let them come
let's get everybody on the same page and
start by having an expert tell us what a
light machine gun is
when machine guns were first created
there were just machine guns
so automatic weapons and fire for as
long as you held down the trigger or the
firing
button or whatever or ran out of
ammunition um
but they began to diversify as most
things do over time
so much smaller more portable and
physically lighter
forms of the machine gun which if
necessary
one guy can operate and that's probably
the best way to think about
a light machine gun it's an automatic
weapon
automatic military weapon that
one guy or a team of two at most carries
with them
into battle doesn't matter how it's fed
it doesn't happen it can be magazine fed
belt fed doesn't actually matter what
caliber it is
the villar peroza what most people think
of as a submachine gun
was actually used by the italians as a
light machine gun
so like most types of firearms it's a
combination of its role what it's
designed to do
so it's a squad machine gun support
weapon
but not not higher up like a company
level gun like a heavy machine gun
and it's also the technical capabilities
of it so it must have automatic fire and
it
nearly always has rifle caliber
ammunition as well
really most shooters are using light
machine guns
no different than the mini gun in the
original doom
it's just a very high capacity
relatively high rate of fire
rifle machine gun whatever they all fire
bullets at the end of the day
so if a light machine gun just fires
lots of bullets why doesn't that
translate into multiplayer shooters
lngs are all about suppressive fire
which is just a fancy way of saying
spitting so many bullets downrange that
people are too afraid to stick their
heads out
that allows your team to move up and
take them out but without the real world
risks
people aren't afraid to stick their
heads up in video games and they
shouldn't be
most of the time the goal is to have fun
and the worst that's gonna happen if you
get taken out is
maybe your kd drops maybe your pride
takes a hit so how do some games even
attempt to simulate fear when players
can just
respawn and try again
that brings us to suppression and why
it's so hard to pull off in video games
developers behind milsim-inspired
shooters like battlefield have tried to
convey the idea of fear to players for
years
but they've never really settled on a
good solution that was both effective
and still fun
battlefield 3 in particular launched
with pretty heavy suppression mechanics
that shook the screen and added a blurry
effect
players hated it and it was toned down
or removed from later titles
games that we love like insurgency
sandstorm and escape from tarkov also
use some
pretty unsettling sound design to get
players to die for cover
it does add a lot of immersion but in
terms of making players afraid to move
it's a bit of a mixed bag in
insurgency's co-op for example top
players still just run through levels
and if you can run through a level with
a light machine gun it's not really
serving its purpose of keeping heads
down
in fact it's probably stealing another
weapon's identity lmgs out of the box
are a
sluggish weapon they weigh a lot they
slow down players they have slow aim
down sights time that means they get
beat by other classes in panic
situations
and hip firing one is typically about as
useful as harsh language
lmg players generally need to do a lot
more planning than anyone else which
means picking a lane mounting a gun
and spraying mounting has been in
battlefield for a long time
but it wasn't part of call of duty games
until more recently so a lot of players
hate this playstyle leading developers
to push the weapon into other weapon
classes
making them faster and more agile like
the infamous bruin that dominated
warzone season 2
but at that point it was basically just
a fast-reacting assault rifle with a
regular mag
or as jonathan put it the light machine
gun is relegated to being a super
assault rifle
it's just an assault rifle with more
bullets you can't really have a super
assault rifle in your game or
what's the point of the assault rifle
category when lmgs stray too far into
other weapon types they can become
better guns than guns already there for
that role it's usually because of what
jonathan said
they have much higher ammo capacity that
means players can have a cheap advantage
in fights by just holding down the
trigger and waiting for the enemy to
reload
that leads to nerfs and the cycle starts
all over again to figure out where lmgs
belong
to tackle this lmg nerfs in the past
have included widening bullet spread
adding massive recoil and lowering
bullet damage
all of this makes the guns way less user
friendly and raises the skill threshold
to use one
that higher skill threshold is
particularly bad in one of the most
popular game modes out there today
battle royale metas are very unforgiving
to players who carry light machine guns
for a large number of reasons
usually the person that wins in the
final circle has high mobility
a fast fire rate or someone with massive
one-shot damage
lmgs are typically behind in all of
these categories in a game like warzone
with loadout drops it's even more common
that the final circle is filled with min
max weapons
chances are the last time you won a
round of war zone it was with an
ar or an smg not the humble light
machine gun
so if the way that lmgs are supposed to
work doesn't really pan out in a battle
royale
what happens if you go to a multi-player
shooter and use them as
intended you get sniped even using an
lmg in its proper style often has bad
results virtually 100 of the time if you
post up
you're going to get domed by a sniper at
the back of the map with a 12x scope
bad company 2 is the first game i can
personally remember that got it right by
armoring stationary machine guns
something other games like apex have
since
tried granted that would make it a
medium machine gun instead of a light
machine gun
but you get the point without something
to stop bullets in front of an lmg
player
they won't last long
at their best lmgs still need two things
to work the player laying down
suppressive fire and a coordinated team
to make use of it
you'll rarely get that in a call of duty
or even battlefield game if you can't
rely on a coordinated team and
nerfs aren't the best dancer what can
you do with a light machine gun to put
it in a unique role
developers have tried a lot of creative
approaches to making lmgs a unique class
of weapons in their game for example
playing with bullet penetration to allow
them to fire through cover that other
weapons can't
or just punch big old honking holes in
walls on that note rainbow six siege
could have tried one thing which was to
make t'chaka's stationary gun the only
weapon in the game that could punch
through carriage shields
let's go guys let's do this shield team
six we're in
fuel some games have gotten more
creative outside of just
messing with handling like bad company 2
that tied lmgs to the medic class in
order to offset their more powerful
abilities having a less friendly gun
encouraged medic players to stay behind
the front line and heal
or revive their teammates or just help
demolish cover more casual games like
apex tried heavy rounds fired out of
lmgs to slow the movement of enemy
players and even the odds
hussain does me better than an lmg games
like cold war made lmgs really good at
destroying vehicles and equipment
in order to rack up scorestreaks which
didn't necessarily require you to kill
players
despite creativity many games struggle
to channel the spirit of an lmg which at
its heart requires players to pick a
lane
and hold it down that's kind of a ball
and chain in a world that favors speed
and fast reactions
lmgs might struggle to have an identity
in games but that doesn't mean that you
don't have your favorites
maybe you love the m60 from bad company
2 or the rpd from modern warfare 2.
hell maybe you're a t'chaka main let
them come
tell us about games that we miss that
you feel handle lmgs really well
while you're at it head on over to
gamespot's youtube page and check out a
host of firearm reacts videos that cover
guns from your favorite games alright
thanks for watching
[Music]
mountains
one